apple's m1 mac mini has been completely
changing the personal computing game
since it was released a couple of months
back at just 699 dollars
it offers the absolute best bang for the
buck that you can get
if you want a mac machine or maybe even
better than a diy
windows pc now they might sound a bit
unrealistic
but i'll explain my reasoning in just a
minute in this long term review
i want to discuss the major benefits as
well as the issues
with the m1 mac mini because it's
definitely
not perfect and at the end i'm going to
discuss
who shouldn't buy the m1 mac mini and
why
but first let me give you a quick
rundown on this machine and why i think
there is
so much value in it the design is very
sleek and compact
compared to most computers out there
with a premium aluminum finish
around back you get some ports including
two thunderbolt ports
two usb a hdmi 2.0 ethernet
and of course a headphone jack the
entire system is cooled by just one
fan but because of the extremely
efficient apple m1 chip
it never runs loud enough to hear it
even while running performance tasks
the reason for that is because this ship
is the first of its kind
while most traditional computer chips
are built on the x86
architecture this one is built on
apple's arm-based architecture
that they've been working on for years
now it's basically a
souped-up iphone or ipad chip but with
added components that help make it a
fully capable computer
like the io chip the thunderbolt
controllers and more
and because it shares the same core
architecture as an iphone
it can actually run your favorite iphone
apps
which wasn't possible before mac apps
run great as well
even ones that haven't been updated for
these new chips
and in our experience this m1 mac mini
feels more snappy
than our 15 000 mac pro for day-to-day
work
for example some apps like audacity and
photoshop
open around twice as fast on the mini
which was completely unexpected
and if you're wondering how that's
possible it's because apple's m1 chip
has an incredibly high single core score
in fact the highest out of any mac ever
but it's not just single core the
multi-core performance is also
incredibly high outperforming the
absolute best chip
in the previous intel mac mini so as you
can tell
the value is definitely there but the
even more impressive part is the
performance of apple's built-in 8-core
graphics chip
it absolutely destroys the previous best
graphics performance in the intel mac
mini
being over 4 times as fast and that's
because the mac mini is way too small
and compact
to be able to fit a dedicated graphics
card or chip
so mac minis have always suffered in
terms of graphics performance
but now that problem is solved thanks to
apple's new m1 chip
and the performance we're getting is
very similar to the base
5300 5300m graphics in this 16-inch
macbook pro
which is really impressive for
integrated graphics
so with the combination of a premium and
compact design
the very reliable mac os software and
very impressive performance
you're truly getting a lot of value for
700
and because of that i want to focus a
lot of this review
comparing the value aspect to other
machines
in its price range let's just say you
have a parent or a relative
who needs a basic computer to browse the
web
do some business or school related work
or anything like that
i strongly believe that the m1 mac mini
is the absolute best choice a similarly
priced intel nok is gonna have much
lower performance
just like intel's mac mini a pre-built
pc like this one
for a similar price is first of all very
large
the fans are gonna run loud and it's
gonna run much
slower so compared to those pre-built
machines
the m1 mac mini is a far better deal so
i took it to the next level
a few months back we made a video where
we built a custom gaming pc
with the goal of it being the best
budget gaming pc
right now the components for the build
come out to over 700 dollars in total
more than the m1 mac mini but keep in
mind that we had to spend a few hours
building it troubleshooting and setting
it up the ryzen 3100 cpu is known as one
of the best bank for the bug
processors but the m1 chip is still
around
37 faster in terms of the cinebench r23
stress test
the rx 560 graphics card is actually
weaker than the m1s graphics
in terms of gfx bench so the mac mini
is still more powerful in every way and
those are actually some of the best
value budget components that we can find
right now we even had to cheap out on
basically everything else
like the case the motherboard the power
supply
and the ssd to get the price anywhere
near the m1 mac mini
and that's even without paying for a
windows 10 license
while the mac obviously gets mac os for
free so as you can see
basically every windows system that you
can get right now
is a much worse value than the m1 mac
mini but besides that
this mac is a whole lot more reliable
because apple controls both the software
and the hardware so it works extremely
well together
and gives you incredible reliability
with windows machines
you usually have a bunch of different
third-party components
working together and those parts are
much more likely to go bad
and have software issues with different
drivers and things like that
but on the other hand the mac mini is
very similar to a pc
since you can pick and choose the mouse
the keyboard
and the display that you use with it and
having the freedom to choose whatever
component you want
can really help bring the price down if
you're on a budget
so based on everything that i discussed
the m1 mac mini ultimately gives you
excellent performance and reliability
for the price
making it in my opinion the new standard
for a personal desktop computer however
while it is great
it's definitely not perfect so let's get
into some of the issues that we
experience with it the biggest issue is
a lack of ports
with the m1 mac mini only offering two
thunderbolt ports
instead of the previous maximum of four
so this means that if you're using a
display that
uses thunderbolt like we do here in the
office
you only have one thunderbolt port left
and because the m1 mac mini doesn't have
an
option for a 10 gigabit ethernet port we
had to use the other thunderbolt port
for our raid storage server now for most
people this isn't a big deal at all
because a lot of people use
hdmi displays leaving the two
thunderbolt ports left
over and most people don't use server
storage
as well those ports are mostly just for
accessories
so it's totally fine since you also have
two
extra usb a ports as well but for that
one person who really needs
more than two thunderbolt ports we found
the perfect solution to the problem
owc's new thunderbolt hub literally
turns
one thunderbolt port into three and then
adds an extra usb a port for
a hundred and fifty dollars so while
that isn't cheap
it's the only way to get extra full
speed thunderbolt ports
this can also help fix the problem of
limited displays
with the m1 chip only being able to
support two displays total
if you're someone who really needs more
than two displays
there are many people out there who have
been connecting up to six displays
to m1 max using hardware adapters and
special software
with really good results so that's great
to hear one of the issues we've been
experiencing is bluetooth connection
problems
but we've really only noticed it with
third party accessories
we used our m1 mac mini with apple's
magic mouse
and had basically no issues but now
apple has just released an update
that improves bluetooth reliability and
users are reporting that the issues seem
to be
finally fixed with one user going two
days
without a disconnect now another one of
the problems that people had
was with video editing people reported
that the encoding quality was worse on
n1 max
compared to previous intel max but we
ended up doing some in-depth testing
and found that the m1s encode it better
than apple's mac pro
which basically shows that it's just
fine so there are no
issues there another problem we had was
with certain plugins
not being supported on apple silicon max
like
m callouts which we use in a lot of our
videos
as of right now most plugins have been
updated to support apple silicon
but there are still some plugins that
are outdated but
thankfully we found a solution on the m
callouts faq section
you can run a script for either final
cut pro or motion
which will force it to run using rosetta
thus allowing those plug-ins to run
again and the performance under rosetta
is still
very fast so those were the main issues
that we've been experiencing
and a lot of them have either been fixed
or have easy solutions to them
and most of them don't even matter to
the average consumer who just needs a
reliable computer
and now if you combine the performance
the efficiency and the reliability
you're truly getting a ton of value for
the cash
especially compared to other desktop
windows pcs that you can get right now
and because of all of that i've got to
say that the m1 mac mini
is by far the best computer to buy for
someone looking for a budget pc
right now but with all of that said
there are actually still some people
who should not buy an m1 mac mini so
let's get into that
if this m1 seems a bit limiting in terms
of the performance or anything else
we are expecting apple to release a more
powerful m1x mac mini in the future
potentially even later this year so keep
that in mind
on top of that we're already expecting a
new imac
coming out within the next few months so
if you don't already have a keyboard
a mouse and a display on hand the imac
will
be a better value if you want a high
quality display
but if the performance of the m1 is
enough for you
then i would totally just buy the m1 mac
mini right now
and enjoy a reliable value computer for
the next five plus years
so there you guys go hopefully you
enjoyed this review and if you did go
ahead and tap the like button
and click the circle above to subscribe
for more videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in
the next video